[Music]
well first of all welcome everybody to
the lecture for tonight I'll be your
host yes miss Carolyn first of all I
want to say it's been a long time since
I've been the GM and res right I mean it
feels like yeah it's been a while I
think it's because we just there's been
so many events going on that have been
doing so many commentaries for that
somehow it's cut into my GM and res
schedule but it's great to be back and
today of course they have all of these
wonderful lecturers mastering the
openings mastering the middle games
doing this doing that forget about it
can't can't can't have a lecturer on any
of those things today lecture is all
about the candidates tournament and what
an amazing amazing event that was the
candidates tournament is really the most
unfair tournament there is in the world
because if you stop and thinking of
think about it you take 8 of the world's
premier top players and you say there's
one prize first if you win first you get
to be challenger to the world champion
excellent
but salmon are going to go home
disappointed right so creating seven
losers for sure and an eight-person
field and when you start the tournament
I would dare say that literally
everybody's got a shot right so at the
very start with these eight premier
players everybody's got 15 percent
chance of winning
well you multiply 8 by 15 you get 120
percent so somebody's going to be less
than 15 percent but let's imagine
that you were to take a player out of
the field I don't know
just pick a player giggling we really
think unfortunately dinkler and out of
the field and replace them with magnus
carlsen very nice right
what's Magnus percentage of winning
first going to be 60% 50% do I hear a
lower that's what that's probably where
everybody's get started we're gonna give
Magnus and I would say about a 20% 25%
chance in other words if you played this
tournament four or five times Magnus
will win once that's pretty nasty just
mathematically just based on pure math
okay not on personal prejudice or you
know who I want to see win and we had
two horses in the field Wesley
yeah and Faby that is to say to
Americans
there was also three Russians in the
field Chris Cook Kramnik and Sergei
Kuryakin so how many thought that
kramnik might went there's a Russian in
the field moving the elections no I mean
collusion yeah so I okay if there's
eight players I had four favorites the
two Americans obviously Kramnik just
because of age you know kind of respect
the veteran and you know and I wouldn't
mind seeing the 14th world champion
versus Magnus Carlsen playing a match
and then of course LaVon because he's
everybody's favorite he's just simply
mr. personality it's just a wonderful
player so those are my first those were
my four picks three did terribly 1-1
yeah
you know like and literally anybody
could have won this tournament one
player who looked like he definitely was
going to win was Vladimir Kramnik coming
out of the gate he had won two drawn one
was leading the tournament and he just
seemed to heaven I take no prisoners
type of attitude he wanted to win this
tournament and really put his mark on it
and not only that if you look at his
games throughout the entire tournament
it was fantastic what he was doing he
was like the drunken machine gunner you
know sometimes he was shooting his own
man you know that was the problem but he
was really amazing and he was bringing
it this game to me was an extraordinary
game but at the same time a very pivotal
game for the tournament kramnik Sanh a
roll he's just jumped out of the
starter's block he's got white against
fabbi my goodness if he wins this he'll
have three and a half out of four he'll
be running away from the field and
everybody will know like this is the guy
you know we've got to be wary of
conversely you know like can fabbi stop
them can he hope so
Vladimir for most of his career
including today has habituate as
habitually Knight f3 c4 g3 Bishop g2
Catalans Reddy's the guy is phenomenal
with his opening repertoire when he
plays one e to e for its first of all
it's sort of like saying okay I'm in a
really feisty mood you know like really
I want to mix it up but ii ii ii four
players are different type of players
you have to have this almost innate
aggression
and so much of the openings with white
when you play E to e for are very far
cry away from nice Knight f3 c4 g3
Catalans and readies some easy breathing
nothing is severe crisis's don't happen
early when you play efore crisis can
happen right away and you have to be
very very well prepared so for me
efore by vladimir is really an
extraordinary testament to his
willingness to play basically everything
and to mix it up now if a bleep lady
five-night f3 Knight f6 and this has
kind of become a key weapon for Fabiano
the petrov defense or the russian
defense depending on which part of the
world you were born in I was born in the
Petra part in Russia they say the
Russian defense and this is a really
annoying defense for white players to
play black is looking for a very solid
game and it's kind of obstinate you
don't like you attack my pawn I'll
attack yours I'm not gonna defend Knight
takes e5 basically this and d4 for me
are really the only alternate alternate
choices D to d4 and this is a very well
mapped out there at a theoretical
dispute as is Knight takes d5 d6
Knight f3 Knight takes e4 so essentially
for well hundreds of years white players
have been faced with this problem how do
I get an advantage now
Queeny - well yeah it's a move but it's
a rather safe move after a queenie -
queenie 7 essentially we can see that
the Queen's get traded and there's
really not too much in the position a
modern the most common line sorry before
I do have a mouse I was wondering if I
had a mouse d4 d5 Bishop d3 Bishop e7
when I played the petrov i played it in
this style and I have had some amazingly
complicated games that resulted from
this line and trust me when I say it's
been mapped out and it goes deeper and
deeper and deeper dozens of moves beyond
this position and lots and lots and lots
of games another modern approach that a
lot of players are taking is does this
play Knight c3 and then after trades
trades White has a little bit of a freer
freer game his pieces go quickly Bishop
e3 Queen d2 and castles long but there's
no targets in blacks position where you
going to beat me you're gonna crush me
on f7 crush me on z7 very very hard to
target and to understand just exactly
where the advantage should go anyway
Queen e2 queenie 793 now this is a new
twist on this very old method in the
past
yeah d3 had been the way that white was
seeking a slight advantage night would
drop back Bishop would come out and
Queen takes Bishop takes Bishop and we
can see that the position symmetrical
except white does have an extra move or
two in the game and whether you play c4
Knight c3 and d4 or whether you play
Knight c3 and castles White has a small
pull but that was not what what Vladimir
wanted okay just a second instead he
played Knight c3 we saw a trade trade
and again a very similar position to the
modern treatment Knight c3 right away
but this time the Queen's are traded off
the board and once I saw this opening I
thought to myself well Happy's doing
great
this is wonderful he's got an easy
equality with the black pieces and
Vladimir didn't have any special opening
preparation to give him trouble I had no
idea what game was going to come out of
this neither did the players I think
both of the players were shocked yeah
afterwards okay Bishop e3 development is
development development good right
Bishop e7 castles and now very to my
mind
very surprising decision to Castle short
putting breaking the cement symmetry
putting the kings on opposite wings I
think a lot of players would have gone
for a typical variation like Bishop e6
let me guess a 95 for just a moment
takes tanks f6 Bishop back king of seven
White has one the two bishops but again
this is a very very solid play you
wouldn't say the bishop on e3 is
particularly fabulous and doing great
things and black again no weaknesses in
the position another approach might be
say b3 castles can be too so from blacks
point of view putting the King on the
kingside matte mirroring what White has
just done makes perfect sense as well h7
h6 taking away the g5 square and again
this would be a typical pattern that
would come out of this position and
finally I wanted to say there was a move
Bishop d7 Bishop d7 rook e1 h 694
castles f4 again White has to create
some kind of imbalance if you allow
black just to play rook e8 and Bishop f6
and fraid well it's going to be a very
easy day in the office for black and a
draw will certainly be agreed and after
this move f4 what we can see is that
white wants to bring his bishop to f3
but white wants to bring his bishop to
f3 and maybe press a little bit on the
kingside by advancing his pawns
again a very small advantage for white
to be sure nothing special but fabbi had
his choice he cancelled short played
Bishop f6 okay
draw I mean what are you gonna do here
with white and if you notice on the open
e file is a bit of a traffic jam these
two bishops one Bishop on e3 billing and
Bishop on e to all all interfering black
will play rook e8 he'll move his light
squared bishop there'll be some trades
trades and a draw so Vladimir and
attempt to increase that the tensions in
the position play tonight d2 I mean
other players may have played 94 and
again it's a very balanced position but
92 has some ideas well the first idea is
the knight wants to come to e4 where
it'll attack the bishop another idea is
to play that typical f4 Bishop f3 and
then once you clear the e-file who knows
maybe some good things can happen for
white so rook e8 just a second I just
wanted to say rook e8 was a very good
move and Bishop f5 would be a mistake
and he takers as to why this move might
be ill-timed Donald your power at once
that's a good reaction to g4 oh sorry
what's a good reaction division thereby
thank you again
Grandmaster Ken where g4 of course the
idea is to gain space to gain time and
if black puts is Bishop back on g6 to
create a threat of f4 f5 trapping the
bishop and all black has done is
endanger this game and given white this
wonderful free Tim excuse me free Tempe
on the kingside so after 92 rook e8 good
move
Bishop f3 the bishop was doing nothing
really on e - pops out on a good
diagonal 95 well
attacking the bishop Bishop f4 pinning
the night along the e-file King f8
breaking the pin defending the rook
Bishop d5 all very straightforward the
game thus far has had a kind of a flow
to it but blacks position again it's
very solid white housing has an edge and
development no targets in blacks
position c7 c6 forcing the bishop back
and now after Bishop b3 you already get
the sense that there are some dangers in
the position there are dangers lurking
but they're lurking for both sides I
need help
what are some of the dangers for black
on on d6 knight on e4 could be very
irritating right what are some of the
potential dangers for white
yeah at the bishop on b3 okay okay we
can imagine a scenario where if black
was able to play to move simultaneously
illegally if he could play both d5 as
well as b5 that Bishop on b3 would be
stuck and out of the game right so from
a very very quiet position suddenly
there are dangers and d-prime me Bishop
f5 developing stopping not well stopping
my d4 but preparing to capture the night
when it jumps to e4 was very nicely
timed and as maybe you can read in my
annotations after this move blacks
opening problems are basically solved if
you can neutralize the threat of 94 then
there's no problem and get black a
little bit of time and d5 is going to be
played as well h3 was Vladimir's move
and again this is I'm not saying that
it's a good or a bad move but I think
that this is a move that a lot of 1.e4
players would not have done in other
words those efore players have this
intuition that you either have to play
very very sharply or to take measures to
neutralize the position h3 is one of
those moves that tries to keep the
position alive for both players age
three stops Knight g4 not necessarily
that it was a threat but it also
prepares the move g4 I think a lot of
other players would have played simply
nighty-night eat for par me
Bishop takes e4 rook takes e4 and after
d5 drop back with the rook now if you
play for example Knight g4 f3 doesn't
help so Knight g4 isn't a threat which
is kind of questions why you had to play
h3 and after g5 Bishop e3 King g7 black
is just fine there's no problem with the
position whatsoever because of that
Bishop on b3 right at Bishop on b3 it's
just wrong
okay so let's say also oops sorry I went
a little bit too far and after h3 g5
this was a really good move just an
honoree counter-attacking move
if white had it in his mind that he
wanted to play g4 move his Bishop from
f4 play f4 and f5 this move g4 just
stops that oh this move g5 just stops
any expansion on the King side and gains
a tempo and gain space so back King g7 C
4 okay so this was a more that a
defensive reaction Vladimir is a little
bit worried that this Bishop on b3 might
get buried okay after d5 and be fine at
the same time it has a very nice idea of
maybe just targeting the pawn on d6 what
Talia said that this palm and this night
on d2 once it moves it could move to e4
it could move to f1 but suddenly that's
a very juicy target on d6 and black has
to react
and you could react slowly rook d8 for
example but then white gets to do what
he wants to do whether it be 94 or night
f1 to e3 and maybe this backward pawn on
d6 is a real problem instead I really
liked what
Fabiana did I think he just hit the the
very right move G for creating counter
play on the kingside at at once
and forcing the action one of the things
that you have to think about too is you
know nobody wants to lose a pond right
you don't want to just lose a pond
without any compensation or something
but one of the things that I think
that'd be very well intuited is even if
he lost the d6 pawn it's going to take
quite some time to capture it by that
time he's creating a lot of counter play
on the kingside and you lose the d6 pawn
but still that Bishop is buried on b3 so
this move g4 forcing counter play was
really nice I liked it when you play a
move like g4 in a sense you're wrecking
your own pawn structure now the pawns on
f7 and H you're gonna play g4 well let's
play h5 you know keep our pawns nicely
but it had a very clear tactical idea
after if you after H takes g4 Knight
takes g4 well you take the pawn on d6
but I'll take the pawn on f2 and if you
play Bishop to g3 Bishop to g5 already
you if things are actually becoming
uncomfortable for white you can envision
you can see that blacks three minor
pieces are actually all very active
this Bishop on g5 pens the knight on D -
maybe on a good day you go h5h for
kicking the bishop on g3 which is
defending the pawn on f2 Black is always
willing to make the swap of Bishop takes
d6 Knight takes F to the central theme
in all of this is the very passive role
of the bishop on b3 it's just not
working okay and if in this position
after g4 94 that was Vladimir choice
Bishop takes e4 rook takes e4 Bishop g5
check this was a very important check
essentially after this check was played
came to be 1 now white one of the
features in the forthcoming middle game
this is always this back rank
checkmating ideas because the king of b1
is vulnerable did you guys see why
Vladimir rejected Bishop f4 yes
yes very nice swishing Zook so night g6
oops the rook on e4 is suddenly hanging
and after rook takes Bishop takes rook
has to come back and now takes two let's
see right here so rook takes because
yeah well the thing is the bishop on g5
is under attack so if I just recapture
the rook I'll be a piece behind after
Bishop takes G fine
oops but with Bishop takes with a check
to the kingdom b1 now black is
threatening to take the rook so that's
why the rook has to drop back now in
this position the salient features are
the fact that this Bishop on b3 is still
buried you might think about lose like
g4 g3 rook e8 night h4 but I just
thought that look
if black just takes plays ricky ain't
blacks for choice that bishop it's going
to be the bishop on b3 versus a very
agile knight and blacks stand better so
Bishop f4 was actually a trap and we
couldn't play vladimir couldn't play
that book
he moved his king g4 takes h3 now here
Vladimir played a shocking move hadn't
occurred to me at all I think myself and
just about everybody in this room would
recapture the pond
she takes h3 and had that happen
G takes h3 a likely variation would be
f5 Knight f3 tanks tanks tanks check and
94 black is basically doing pretty good
the knight on e4 attacks the bishop on
d6 attacks the pawn on f2 and whites
Queen side majority and two bishops are
not that meaningful the Queen side
majority is doubled and the two bishops
again the bishop bishop on b3 is not
working I think black is just doing fine
and the position is if anything a little
bit better for black but it should be a
draw
vladimir didn't do this he made a move i
didn't even consider actually i mean as
far as a move i actually considered
maybe that's okay that's a very decent
move f4 there's a problem with f4 is
that while the move attacks to black
minor pieces don't forget there's a
still this pawn on h3 you know so I'll
go like oops excuse me I'll go Knight g4
attacking the rook forcing is a swap and
now you can take my bishop but I'll take
your bishop
and again this stupid bishop on b3 we're
gonna have a rook and a rook and rook
and minor piece versus minor piece but
black is doing very well the other thing
is in these positions you always got to
calculate taking on g2 because that pond
you know like moving the night away we
will trade rooks you take my bishop I
may take the pawn kind of thing I had
expected G takes h3
f-five and this is that variation sorry
that I just pointed out vladimir came up
with conception I have not thought about
at all
c5 on the one hand this is a very very
desirable move you open up the bishop on
b3 yay after speaking for the last 10
minutes on how bad this Bishop on b3 is
suddenly it has a wonderful view you're
hitting the pawn on d6 undermining the
support of the knight on e5 brilliant
brilliant brilliant except wait a minute
the guy captured upon a moment ago what
have you captured no no I mean this is
really really scary stuff and Vladimir
had to calculate extremely deeply to get
the courage let's just put it that way
to go into this line okay
from Fabiano's point of view you really
didn't have too much choice he doesn't
want to see white simply playing c5
takes d6 and d7 and this knight on e5 is
going to have to move played f5
attacking the rook now the rook can't
come back to e1 I'll take on g2 and
Knight f3 and that's all she wrote rook
to b4 oh my goodness
but White has no choice because black is
just crashing through on the King side H
takes g2 and there we go check the King
had to go back to not the most happy
square but it's safe on h8 a good square
C takes D 6 Knight f3
oh my work oh my word
there's a spot on g2 and how do we stop
this pond from queening I mean why do we
got a and there's this pawn on d7 d sex
it's gonna go to d7 with the tempo
hitting the rook it's one square away
from queening as well chaos on the board
right okay but here Vladimir's intended
move he realized was wrong Vladimir had
intended the move Bishop did she want
I got a hide Vladimir had reasoned that
when he went into this line with c5 that
things aren't so bad I mean it's
dangerous but things aren't so bad for
him
on a good day he wants to go Bishop a4
takes pawn on c6 takes pawn on g2 sweet
h5 is way too slow
h5 Bishop a4 h4 Bishop takes c6 and
White gets there first but then he
realized that this was very bad position
for him what had he missed and what does
he now see then
maybe rookie one so that after rook
takes II one let's take a look
rookie one yeah oh sorry
it look take see one guy takes one let's
say hmm I'm wondering about f4 but okay
let's say Bishop here Knight f3 Bishop
Munch's pawn Knight Munch's Bishop
Bishop Munch's pawn rook D 8 D 7 if
white is allowed rook takes a 7 black is
facing four connected that's [ __ ] I
mean it may not be a fun fight if white
is allowed to go c4 c5 c6 that will not
be fun either so we need a better move
than rook e1 we mean because Vladimir
rejected the line because of blacks next
turn what did he see
ninety-two check just will force the
king no harm no foul can 92 know that
night on f3 is beautiful I mean now
we've already decided that H 5 H 4 H 3
is way too slow
that takes 5-10 P and by that time
Bishop a4 takes c6 will have been played
but what is the purpose of controlling
an open file Ben sorry Ben so we are
excuse me sorry we are here bishop g1
and what would you so yes of course
rookie 2 rookies one trading rooks
misses the point
rookie to the whole idea of controlling
the open file is to penetrate usually to
the second or seventh rank and after
rook e 2 if we play a four for example
rook d2
ooh this is your idea can so that in
case of a trade of rooks or maybe this
is also like Ben's idea as well how
embarrassing is that I mean you know you
don't even get to sacrifice your bishop
for the pot but I hate the bishop is
simply trapped and if you move the rook
then simply rook takes d6
there goes your pride and joy and the
rook is now under attack from the bishop
on g5 now if we go back for a second to
this moment and after rookie two let's
say we play a different move than a four
let's say we play the move Bishop f7 so
what's the idea of behind Bishop f7
actually twofold one idea is to be able
to play Bishop back to h5 attacking the
knight another idea is that we're
stopping the rook doubling and playing
rook to e1 right but then there is rook
to d2 rook takes Knight takes King a one
night f3 rook back Knight takes rook
here night here rook takes now this
position is actually winning for black
he is a piece up but there's problems
okay problems so from the start right
here there was another line rookie -
Bishop f7 Knight takes g1 just very
simple rook takes g1 rook takes F - ooh
now you're threatening rook F one check
and mate and black is really really fast
I mean his pawns are you know you could
play
like Bishop c4 but his pawns are ready
to rumble f4 f3 and wins okay he's just
too fast okay
and now since Bishop g1 that was
Vladimir this was not the plant
but Vladimir is ready to go Bishop takes
c6 Bishop takes g2 and life is gonna get
interesting that there when a piece
Bishop takes c6 okay
now here you can understand that the
players were nearing time trouble okay
and fabbi spent some very very precious
minutes right here you got this Bishop
hitting e8 as well as g2 if you could
play the move Knight f1 you get to Queen
right but then Knight f1 runs in the
bishop takes g2 so fabbi wanted to play
rook efore how sweet right rookie four
so that then he could play Knight f1 and
after just second it's Bishop takes e4 I
want yes after Bishop takes e4 takes
rook here push III now if you take on g2
rook takes G - E - oh my gosh if you
play rook g1
that's so sweet right isn't that sweet
those moves
so Bishop takes pawn takes rook here III
now if you play F takes III now what do
you do ooh threatening the back Frank
checkmate you don't have time to take
the fun on g2 and bang you're coming
down so you can understand why Fabiano
was really looking at rookie four and
thinking oh man I'm winning I'm winning
if he takes the rook the problem is is
that after rook g1 now if you play rook
e8 takes takes c4 it's a complete mess
white is threatening to take on g2 he's
threatening to place c5 and you lost
control of the position so Fabiano
played a really nice move here he played
rook b8 and let's face it that's a
really hard move to play okay his idea
is to play book takes d6
give me the pawn there's a back rank
mate if you take the rook Knight f1
we're back to our old friend Knight f1
let me just put that on the board they
said there's something I just find so
enormous Lee oh sorry
I did it in the wrong move order excuse
me
rook takes here rook here takes takes
Knight f4
that's just enormous ly pleasing dude to
break the rook like that okay
so Abby's Abby's doing really well this
is gonna be a little bit of a longer
lecture that I hadn't anticipated
because the lines are just so fantastic
Bishop takes rook d8 okay crazy things
are happening if I take the pawn on g2
you take the pawn on d6 I'm a piece down
and I'm busted I gotta play d7 okay now
the rook is under attack clear rook here
Bishop takes rook takes Bishop here now
in this position the happies really
really low on time okay I really low on
time but he knows he's a piece up he's
winning the game for sure what's your
instinctive move so Fabiano chose Knight
g4 and it's very very hard to criticize
this move because I think it's a very
instinctive move whether your knight on
h2 is not in the game so you want it on
III you could play Knight f12 III maybe
you would play Knight f1 because maybe
you want to put your knight on D too
with a check okay but here's another way
of thinking about it that night that's
so stupid on h2 is actually doing a lot
of good it's controlling the F 3 and F 1
squares why move it at all so I'm
critical of the move Knight g4 and I
give it a question mark and yet we all
understand the move you want to bring
your piece back into the game but I
think fabbi missed a very simple win
with f4 let's see how the game might
have gone pardon me
right here it would be rook takes a 7f
three now again you're facing four
connected passed pawns you know they're
coming down the board but now the f3
pawn is really making a statement as
well let's say you play rook a3 to stop
to do to be able to play rook to the 3rd
how's this for a move now you're a piece
up you can see the pawns on the Queen
side are completely stopped you're not
playing a 4 a 5 any time soon you're not
playing b4 because Bishop f6 will likely
be a mate you're not playing c4 in the
meantime you are playing to push your
own h-bond that is a very easy and
simple advantage another nice one is to
play Knight f1 not to trade rooks the
idea is that after rook takes f3 check
you get the bishop now your first
immediate gut reaction might be uh-oh
panic it's I'm up a rook but I'm facing
four connected passed pawns but then you
look a little bit and you go wait a
minute those pawns aren't going anywhere
after Bishop c6h5 black is ready to go H
4 H 3 H 2 rook takes d7 and you're a
long way away from going c4 c5 and so
forth so I think that this was a really
nice and easy win
now here would be a wonderful moment for
me to just stop and say well thank you
for the evening thank you for coming
it's a cliffhanger lecture we got to
come back we just saw this one wonderful
move rook b8 d7 rookie - Bishop takes G
2 and here Fabiana could and should have
just
he pushed his f-pawn up the board and
made it a very key factor instead he
took some time to reposition the knight
which is fine but after this move this
is where he makes a very big error okay
and again it's time it is his clock is
ticking he's down to his final seconds
he played h6 protecting his bishop I
think it's a safe sound instinctive
reaction especially when you're down on
time the problem is rook takes g5 is no
threat
there's made on the back rank so here
was a wonderful opportunity to play rook
take c2 attacking the bishop if the
bishop moves back to a4 then you go back
to after you still can't take the bishop
because it made on the back rank and you
stole one of the very very important
pawns in White's position if you take
that c2 pawn and put it on c7 you're
scared to death you take that C to pawn
off the board no worries about the pawn
moving up you're okay
and once you've taken the c2 pawn you
can play Bishop f6
fabbi in time trouble made the
understandable decision of what we call
playing it safe he played the move h7 h6
but this gave Vladimir the time he
needed to create his own threads now
vladimir plays rook c7 his ideas rook c8
rook takes g5 oopsy-daisy King g7 so
Fabiano's idea
is again rook takes g5 there's a check
made on the first rank so you don't have
time to play rook takes g5 he wants to
get his king over to the king side to e7
pardon me
a4 here we go yes now king of seven
Bishop a4 king e7 okay again this is
just time trouble playing games rearing
its ugly head
the King is perfectly fine on f7 it
doesn't need to be on e7 what is needed
is to get that F pawn going f4 and a
likely variation would be a 5 f3 rook c8
rope g2 rook H 1 f2 now we can see that
the pawn on f2 is a real factor in the
position yeah okay and he needed to do
that instead he played in time trouble
kingi 7 and now the game changes
dramatically
a5 and now it's very easy to see that
white wants to play a 6 a 7 rook c8
Queen what you're gonna do
rook
remember in some variations we were
playing rook a3 to come back to deal
with the Jeep on its Fatty's turn in
time pressure the panic he wants to play
rook to be for her to try to deal with
these ponds Vladimir says uh-uh-uh
you're not gonna get a switch across a
good question is why didn't he play c4
I'm not too sure maybe he was afraid
that if you play C for fab he would go
back with his rook to f2 and play Bishop
to b2 attacking bishop to f6 attacking
the b2 c3 king d6 time trouble again and
another blunder mistake by Fabiano and
after this move he's much worse why is
this move bad what's a good move for
white but I'll though Bravo
rook the c6 check in in case of King
takes d7 check
and on the next move white will take the
bishop on g5 remember when he played h6
securing the bishop how good he must
have felt
imagine how bad you feel the guy just
takes the pawn with check which means
after rook c6 check Fabiana would have
to move his king away right which means
just a loss of two turns and now a6 you
again you cannot take the pawn on d7
with your king you have to take it with
the rook rook down and now white is
threatening to take the rook and to play
a7 making a new girl you have to play
rook here and then rook check
oops in one variation you lost your
bishop in this variation that's your
night looks like what's what's up with
these minor pieces and now you're in a
position where it's very very good for
white cousin second let me make sure
we're okay so rook c6 check King e7 and
did I do this yeah I stopped right here
I thought I had written it down so this
was a moment that glad America have won
the game and then he would have been at
three and a half half and who could have
stopped Vladimir Vladimir and time
trouble himself played rook b7 which
isn't a bad looking move either right
again on a good day you just want to go
a 6 a 7 rook b8 sign my score she let me
go have a dinner okay rook g4
now fabbi says okay
finally I get it I need to make my
f-pawn a factor in fact Fabiano cannot
stop a six a seven rook b8 equals Queen
he invites white to play rook takes g4
f5 takes G four and now his Jeep on will
be racing up the board rookie wants
avoiding F for a six h5 rook a a so the
player somehow okay the time trouble is
over right and they've gotten themselves
into this complete mess blacks a piece
up but that's not the salient feature of
the position white can play rook b8 and
make a queen and win a piece back
anytime he wants it's it's all about
these pawn races okay I was sure that
white was winning now the players kind
of stopped gathered themselves and
kramnik immediately after the time
control lots of thinking came up with
this
bad move what the heck was he thinking
he's thinking he wants to play C 5 C 4 C
5 check but he wants to play b4 so that
after C 5 check the pawn on c5 is
supported but first of all notice this
as a rook on g4 right so that black is
going to play f3 f2 and this rook on g4
is controlling the fourth-ranked
b4 was not only a loss of tempo a
crucial loss of tempo it ends up that
the pawn isn't very good on v4 Vladimir
in my opinion could have still been
winning the game after c4 f3 Queen
though what's that Queen now if you take
with the rook I go rook b8 so you've got
to take with the bishop I take the
knight
you gotta go f2 I get behind it you
gotta go check I go here Queen but now
do you see what Vladimir missed c5 check
oh how sweet that is King takes e5
bishop takes and now who's got the more
dangerous pawns Wow
nice and this is probably a win for
Vladimir at least I thought so and it
was this crucial moment right here that
he played this bad move d4 and again
seafood was a winning moment some of
these moves are just so surprising but
now you can see I'm threatening that
pawn on f3 I'm threatening Ruby 8 and I
got this tricky move c5 check so that
the bishop on b5 covers the promotion
square ooh nice let's go back to the
game because the game is still thrilling
b4 h4 c4
a ch3 wait a minute who who who's pawns
are winning the race here a moment ago
we wanted to go rook b8 right like Queen
and rook b8 now fabbi wants to go h2
rook h1 and he's in time check King in
the middle of the board for connected
pious pawns so you got to analyze c6h to
c7 it's crazy but now suddenly fabbi is
doing well this H pawn has really
changed dramatically the position rook
takes a 7
rook over sweet so now
vladimir wants to take the bishop and
queen or he wants to queen you take the
new queen rook takes g4 and thanks to
the fact that the knight is pinned you
lose a rook so here rook g8 was the move
let's say we could Queen if we like yeah
let's do it let's have some fun Queen
okay Bishop takes rook takes h2 ooh
now the rook is coming down to g1 this
is this is this is very serious okay
let's see what he did he played rub g8
Bishop f6 Queen what the heck is going
on here folks
can somebody please please explain to me
why Vladimir Kramnik did not capture
this rook
why didn't he play rook takes that is
such an obvious move I can't believe a
grandmaster of his caliber wouldn't win
a rook Talia Oh
instead of winning a rook there's a
sudden threat of rook a1 checkmate would
that where did that come from the bishop
on f6 why did he play b4 if that pawn
was still on b2 that wouldn't have been
a threat oh my word now black is winning
because of this double attack King f5
attacks the rook rook a1 is mate which
is why after Bishop f6 he queen and now
he took the rook ok but now it's still
crazy right like who is doing what to
whom Bishop f6 well nobody gets any
credit for guessing what black's threat
yeah rook g6 rook here and again that
pawn on b4 is really annoying now here
all of your chess engines will say draw
that or zero zero zero and we all
expected that it was going to be a draw
and Fabiano found a blunder night c2
vladimir was expecting a draw and he
would he he he thought that for example
after king f5 he was going to make it he
was going to accept a draw or offer a
draw so any reasonable move vladimir
was going to make a draw Fabiana found
the one move in the position that
encouraged vladimir to play on fabbi
played the move Knight c2 and offered a
draw
yeah vladimir said no way
okay Knight d4 Bishop d3 check back
Knight B 3 check King d5 King c2 did
this go right there was King d5 right so
he could take on f6 rook check King D -
let's say pardon me he could take here
check here check and could make an easy
draw by just moving the King and let's
say moving the King and make an easy
draw he played something instead he
didn't find me he didn't take he played
King c2 check and he he ended up having
he played King b1 Knight f3 and this was
the move I think he had missed Knight f3
oh my word
suddenly again the bishops hanging
Brooke is hanging there's mating ideas
possibilities of rook F 1 check and
again the players are in time trouble
rook D 1 and check rook takes and now
there's a problem
if you take with the king can you tell
me what black would play age to rook
over then remember those variations with
the knight was blocking on f1 this is
like again the Knights like playing
exactly obstruction so Vladimir played
Bishop a6 check check and took the pawn
and it was lost and I think he resigned
here what again was this just like not
amazing I mean the players should we
applaud to the players even though
they're not even a year right this game
turned the tournament around that
Vladimir was at +2 and I think he
finished on a - score like things went
south after this
Fabiano went on took a lead kept it
until round 12 and maybe we'll save some
more action for more lectures
you
[Music]